PROFESSOR: OK.
So today's lecture is devoted,
in some sense, to this tying
up of loose ends.
I have from you, 29
single-spaced pages worth of
questions, which you asked in
your directed exercise nine.
And I'm going to answer
all of them in detail.
Actually I'm not going to answer
I'm going to try to pick out
some of the ones that I think
will be of general interest and
welcome those of you whose
questions aren't answered to
come by during office hours.
So one way to think about what
we do when we encounter an
article in this class is
thinking about what you do
when you encounter a building
for the first time-- say, the
Eiffel Tower--
and are given guidance
about how to make
sense of that building.
So one of the things that I've
tried to do for each of the
articles or books that we've
read is just to give you a
sense of its general shape.
To give you a sense of what's
distinctive about it, to give
you a sense of how it's
structured internally and how
that internal structure
determines what it is that
we're able to do with that
article and what it is that
that article is able
to illuminate.
But I've tried, in certain
cases, to give you a sense of
the neighborhood in which that
article can be found, just as
in talking about the Eiffel
Tower, I might show you where
in Paris it's located.
Or I might try to give you a
sense of how that article
relates to other approaches
of the same kind --
how the Eiffel Tower
relates to other
iconic monumental buildings.
The question of the relation
between the individual
articles that we read for today
and the larger framework
is primarily something
that I'll discuss
in Thursday's lecture.
Though I'll get at some of it
in comparing and contrasting
the political philosophy
views today.
What I want to do a bit more of
today is to look at some of
the details of some of the
arguments and articles and
writings that we've considered
in the way that we might look
at part of a building and ask
how it's structured there,
recognizing that in so doing,
there's lots of other parts of
the building to which we
don't pay attention.
Or we might want to ask, with
respect to what sort of
problem is the building
constructed?
Here are the plans for
the Eiffel Tower.
So the goal in today's lecture
is, with regard to a number of
the questions that you raised
in your directed exercise
nine, to look at some of the
details of some of the
arguments and, to a smaller
extent, to put those in a
larger framework.
Now in so doing, it's
important for me to
acknowledge that there are
a tremendous number of
interesting questions that you
asked that I'm not even going
to come close to answering.
There were a large number of
very interesting questions
about the connections between
the political philosophy of
Rawls and Nozick, for example,
and the U.S. Constitution.
I'm not going to have anything
to say about that.
There were questions asked about
the childhoods of the
various authors that we read
and how that might have
affected their views.
I'm not going to have much
to say about that.
And perhaps my favorite
question: I was asked, if I
could have coffee at Blue State
with any one of the
authors that we had read this
semester, who would I choose?
And I guess I wouldn't choose
Robert Nozick because he
wouldn't want to go
to Blue State.
But beyond that it's
hard to know how
to answer that question.
So what I'm going to do today
is basically in three parts.
The first large part of the
lecture, I'm going to go over
in some detail a leftover
item from our
lecture two classes ago.
That is, say a little bit about
Cass Sunstein on norms.
And I'm going to use that as a
way of segueing into certain
puzzles that we face about
heuristics and the question of
how those fit into the dual
processing tradition.
But that will also be a major
focus of Thursday's lecture.
So please don't be disappointed
if I don't get to
your question in that section.
And then I'll close that section
by identifying for
you, a cluster of courses that
you might be interested in
taking if that was the part of
this class that interested you
most.
I'll then have some things to
say about the political
philosophy section
of the course.
And I'll close today's lecture
with the moral philosophy
section of the course, each time
indicating places to go
next if you were particularly
moved by some of the readings
that we did.
So let's start with a somewhat
detailed introduction to what
it is that Cass Sunstein said
in the 1996 article that we
read for last Tuesday's class.
What Sunstein is attempting
to do in that piece is to
identify the ways in which our
attitudes towards certain
kinds of behaviors on our part
and the part of others towards
certain sorts of decisions on
our part and the part of
others are affected by what he
calls, drawing from a large
body of sociological literature,
social norms.
Social norms are basically
social attitudes of approval
and disapproval that specify,
through the kinds of tacit
mechanisms that human beings
as social primates have for
expressing disapproval
and approval of
one's and other's actions.
That is, social attitudes of
approval and disapproval
specifying what ought
to be done and what
ought not to be done.
Subtle things like nuanced
facial expressions,
approaches, avoidances, all of
the social cues to which we
are extraordinarily sensitive
in infancy, to which we are
extraordinarily sensitive in our
early years, to which we
are absolutely, exquisitely
sensitive in middle school and
high school.
And to which we continue to be
sensitive throughout our life.
What Sunstein points out is that
social norms determine
social meanings.
That is, they determine the
attitudes and commitments that
a particular type of
conduct signals.
So, he points out, if you fasten
your seatbelt in a
country where seatbelt use is
not the norm then you express
in so doing implicit criticism
of the ability of your driver
to navigate the car effectively
on the highway.
Fastening your seatbelt
is an insult.
When my family and I rent cars
in Eastern Europe, where my
husband is from, rental cars
typically come, if you don't
rent them from a major agency,
with a small metal plate that
you can slide into the seatbelt
lock without having a
seatbelt attached to it so
that the annoying beeping
sound goes off and you
don't have to wear
your insulting seatbelt.
Whereas in nations where
seatbelt use is the norm,
where seatbelt use is in fact
the law, the failure to fasten
your seatbelt is an expression
of disrespect.
When I was growing up my
family, to my great
embarrassment, separated its
vegetable scraps from its
paper scraps and put them
in the backyard
into a compost heap.
The social meaning of a compost
heap in the 1970s in
suburban Massachusetts was
one of non-normativity.
It was one of an expression,
perhaps, that we were more
socially conscious than our
neighbors, perhaps thought we
were better than
our neighbors.
But whatever it was it wasn't
a way of fitting in.
It is now the case in large
portions of America that a
compost heap or the carrying
of a recyclable bag or the
replacement of your light bulb
with a full-spectrum long-term
bulb simply expresses respect
for the environment rather
than an outlier attitude.
My Hungarian nephew, when he
came to visit us this summer,
wore what he thought to be
very stylish Iron Maiden
t-shirts, which in Budapest were
in expression of cool.
In our suburban Connecticut
environment, his actions were
often misperceived as rebellious
because of the
social signals that
his clothing sent.
So the reason that I had you
read the Sunstein article in
the context of our political
philosophy discussion was to
point out to you how many more
layers of complexity there are
when we start thinking about
what kind of social structures
are legitimate.
There was, in addition, a very
particular question about the
Sunstein article, which was
raised in the context of our
feedback page, about which I
want to say a small bit by way
of transition.
So one of the students asked
whether I could characterize
Sunstein's somewhat complicated
argument about
willingness to pay and
willingness to allow.
So what we're doing now is
we're looking at a very
particular girder of a very
particular argument.
So Sunstein in that article, you
may recall, introduces a
discussion of what's known as
the endowment effect, which is
basically the tendency of human
beings to demand more to
give up an owned object then
they would be prepared to pay
to acquire that object.
And the term for how much it is
that somebody's willing to
sell something for is WTA,
willingness to accept payment,
whereas the term for that which
somebody's willing to
pay for an object is WTP,
or willingness to pay.
It turns out that if I have a
beautiful Yale mug, which I
seek to sell to you, that our
assessments of its value will
very often differ.
I may well say that I won't part
with my beautiful mug for
anything less than $10.
Whereas you say, "I wouldn't
buy your crappy old mug for
anything more than $5." Even
if, when we alter the
situation and you have the
mug and I don't, our
responses are inverted.
I wouldn't buy your crappy old
mug for anything more than $5
and you wouldn't part with it
for anything less than $10.
Now Sunstein, 15 years ago in
this article, hypothesizes
that what explains this effect
is primarily something about
social norms. It looks like, at
least to some extent, that
he was wrong about that.
At least that he was wrong
that social norms fully
explain the phenomena.
Because research done in Laurie
Santos lab at this very
university in the last five
years seems to suggest that
something akin to the endowment
effect can be found
even in Capuchin monkeys.
A tendency to value more that
which is yours than that which
is not, even when the objects
are identical.
That said, there is still reason
to think that Sunstein
is on to something when he
argues that the willingness to
pay, willingness to allow
distinction, in some ways is
tracking something about
social meaning.
So he points out that in a
series of studies done in the
context of behavioral economics
with WEIRD subjects
near the University of Chicago,
for at least Western,
educated, industrialized, rich,
democratic, adults, it
looks like this asymmetry
is rather profound.
So he described this study,
the details of which I had
thought I would go through but I
won't, in which what you see
is a rather radical asymmetry
in subject's willingness to
either acquire an object from
another or part with an object
that they own.
Sunstein's response to these
sorts of cases is to suggest
that the difference here has a
lot to do with social norms
and meanings.
So that being willing to, for
example accept a certain
amount of money to allow the
extinction of a species has a
very different social
meaning than--
what you might think of as
structurally the same--
accepting, or being willing to
pay a certain amount of money
to prevent the extinction
of the species.
Whether you consider the state
of the world where the species
is extinct or whether you
consider the state of the
world where the species is
present and it's your job to
save it, to be the baseline,
turns out to affect people's
evaluation of it.
And Sunstein suggests in the
article, more generally, that
numerous of our actions,
numerous of our decisions, are
driven at least in part
by internal and
external social meaning.
And that, as a consequence,
an effective mechanism for
influencing actions and
decisions is to influence the
social meanings of those
actions and decisions.
So that, he suggests, it turns
out to be an inevitable role
of government to regulate
behavior by the affirmation or
introduction or disavowal
of certain
kinds of social meaning.
And we address the issue of
this sort of indirect
non-rational control of behavior
in the context of our
discussion of Plato
on censorship.
Now this distinction between
willingness to pay and
willingness to allow, the
details of which we're now
going to set aside, can be used
to think about one of the
examples, which we talked about
in many lectures and
which we'll talk about
again on Thursday.
Namely, the fact that there is
an undeniable tendency of
people, this class included, to
respond differently to the
classic trolley case, where one
diverts a trolley from a
track where it's about to hit
five onto a track where it's
about to hit one, and trolley
cases involving pushing
someone off a bridge.
So whereas the first one among
you produced only 15% of you
saying that it was prohibited
to turn the trolley, the
second case, the one where
you're asked to push the fat
man off the bridge, thereby
killing one and saving five,
produced among you
a 78% conclusion
that the act was forbidden.
Next lecture we'll talk a lot
about how to reconcile
intuitions about particular
cases with more general
principled commitment.
But what I want to do now is
just, by way of answering a
couple of questions, point out
to you three different ways
that one might respond
to what's
going on in this asymmetry.
One might, making use of the
vocabulary that Sunstein just
introduced, say that what's
going on in the case of fat
man is a case where one's being
asked to accept a cost.
Accept the cost of having one
die in order to save five.
Whereas what's going on in the
case of the switch is that
one's being asked to pay a cost
-- something that wasn't
part of the calculus
to begin with --
pay a cost of having one
die to save five.
And we know as a matter
of general theory,
that the way human--
and perhaps even non-human --
primate accounting works, that
that the cost of accepting
something feels higher to us
than the cost of paying.
So perhaps what's going on in
the trolley cases is that we
are assimilating them, by means
of a heuristic mechanism
that we often use, to a familiar
kind of reasoning
process, one that may or may
not be tracking our moral
commitments.
Or perhaps as the cases were
originally suggested to show,
what we're tracking here in our
different responses is a
deep and profound morally real
distinction between violating
rights and considering utility,
where in cases that
violating rights comes into
play, letting one die or
killing one in order to save
five is morally wrong.
Whereas in cases where rights
don't come into play, letting
one die or killing one to save
five is morally acceptable.
Or perhaps what's going on in
this case is, as Josh Greene
suggests on the basis of his
neuroimaging work, that in one
of the cases we're responding
emotionally and in the other
case we're responding
rationally.
What the first and the third,
but not the second, response
have in common --
that is, what the two responses
that suggest we
should take as differentially
informative our responses to
the fat man case and our
responses to the bystander
case suggest --
is that in thinking about these
cases we are thinking
about one of them primarily with
one mode of thought and
the other primarily with another
mode of thought.
And throughout the course, we
have been introduced to the
fact that in every intellectual
tradition there
has been a suggestion that human
understanding of the
world proceeds in
multiple ways.
The contemporary scientific
vernacular of this makes use
of the notion of dual
processing.
It suggests that there are
two systems: System
one and system two.
Where system one is
evolutionarily primitive and
shared with non-human animals,
whereas system two is
evolutionarily recent and
shared, if with any animals at
all, only with those closest
to us in the
evolutionary tree.
System one is unconscious or
preconscious whereas system
two is conscious.
System one is automatic
whereas system two is
controlled.
System one is effortless
whereas
system two is effortful.
System one is fast whereas
system two is slow.
System one is associative
whereas system two is
rule-based.
Now one of the things that
we've done throughout the
course is to look at various
ways of getting at the
distinction that this particular
version gets at
without trying to decide which
of these frameworks is the one
that's most useful
in all contexts.
But rather, by recognizing that
in certain domains it may
be useful to speak, as Plato
does, of spirit and appetite
pulling in one direction and
reason pulling in another.
That it might be useful in some
contexts to speak as I do
of alief causing certain kinds
of nonreflective behaviors
while belief causes certain
kinds of reflective ones.
That it might be useful in
some contexts to speak of
heuristics as causing us to
respond in one sort of way and
full cognition--
or reflection --
in causing us to respond
in another.
But it's important to know
that in picking out those
three particular ways that we
looked at this overarching
distinction, that we neglected
to look at the many, many
other sorts of dual processing
accounts.
Here are 15 or so taken from the
Evans article that we read
in mid-January.
And that for the purposes of our
discussion in this course,
the similarities among these
views are more relevant than
the differences.
If however, you are intrigued by
the set of questions, which
I've just quickly run through,
there are numerous
places to go next.
Most of the courses offered by
the cognitive science program
look at the sorts of issues
that I've just been
discussing.
How is human reasoning affected
by structural
features of the brain?
To what extent can we
systematize the sorts of
errors that human beings seem
to make in reasoning?
To what extent are those
sorts of errors-- or
what we call errors--
actually effective means for
navigating various sorts of
environments?
You can also look at these
sorts of questions in the
context of social psychology,
cognitive psychology,
developmental psychology, and
there will be numerous courses
offered in psychology next year
that will go in much more
depth into the questions that
I've just been mentioning.
The School of Management offers
courses in behavioral
economics, which are open to
undergraduates who have the
requisite background.
And in the context of the
philosophy department, there
are historical courses that look
seriously and in depth at
Plato alone.
Indeed there's a course this
semester that just reads
Plato's Republic.
There are courses that
at Aristotle
or Aristotle's ethics.
Courses that look at each of
the authors that we've been
considering.
So intrigued by what we've
just talked about,
many places to go.
Second big cluster of topics
that I want to address
questions with regard to.
I was asked--
perhaps because they
came so recently--
by almost a third of the
questions, to discuss again
the relation between Nozick
and Rawls and to say
something, perhaps, about how
that fits together with Hobbes
and the social contract
theory.
So borrowing from my colleague
Thomas Pogge, here's a helpful
way for thinking about
the difference among
the three of them.
And I'll give you first an
overview of the difference and
then try to present you with a
systematic explanation of just
where Hobbes, Rawls and Nozick
are similar and different.
So all three of them are working
in what is known as
the social contract tradition.
All three of them are making the
contention that it is in a
certain kind of interest on the
part of human beings to
contract into a certain sort of
social structure even if in
so doing they give up some
of their freedom.
Hobbes argues that it is of
prudential utility for us to
engage in a social contract.
We are better off than we would
have been had we not
been part of a state.
But the state of nature to
which Hobbes appeals is a
purely imaginary one.
It is a hypothetical contract,
whose value to us is
prudential.
Rawls suggests that it is of
moral utility for us to engage
in the sort of social contract
that the Rawlsian state
represents.
We imaginarily go into the
original position behind the
veil of ignorance.
And in so doing come up with
something morally worthy.
Nozick, in contrast, to Rawls
is concerned with how things
actually came into being.
But like Rawls is interested
in what sort of moral
justification that provides.
So whereas Hobbes is interested
in what a
hypothetical contract tells us
about what's prudential for
us, Rawls is interested in what
a hypothetical contract
tells us about what's moral and
Nozick is interested in
what a certain historical set
of events, where that stands
with respect to morality.
So let's start by looking
at Hobbes' argument.
Hobbes presents us, in Leviathan
with what he calls
the state of nature.
An imaginary situation, what
the "manner of life there
would be with no common power
to fear." Where life is
"solitary, poor, nasty, brutish
and short." And he
suggests that our prudential
aim, that which is of use to
us, is to escape the
state of nature.
Why?
Because all of us have a "fear
of death, the desire for
commodious living, and the hope
that by our industry we
might obtain it." But, says
Hobbes, that gives rise, if we
think about the fact that being
in the state of nature
is bad for us, to a number
of rationally mandated
conclusions, of which
we examined three.
These are what Hobbes calls
the laws of nature.
The things, which we realize
rationality demands of us if
we have the prudential aim
of commodious living.
In particular, we need to seek
peace if there's a chance of
obtaining peace and if not
reserve for ourselves the
right of war.
First law of nature.
We need to lay down our rights
to the extent that others are
willing to do the same.
Second law of nature.
And we need to perform our
covenants, that is keep our
promises, assuming that others
are willing to do the same.
But there is a structural
problem with our doing so.
The structural problem is the
one articulated by the
Prisoners' Dilemma.
And because of that, says
Hobbes, the only way that we
can do what rationality demands
of us: seek peace, lay
down our rights and perform our
covenants, thereby acting
on the first half of each of
these clauses, is if we
institute an authoritarian
government.
A civil power sufficient to
compel non-defection in a
prisoners' dilemma.
So note the four key steps.
Because I'm going to go through
these next with Rawls
and next with Nozick.
We're interested in a situation,
a rationally
mandated conclusion and a
structurally mandated mechanism.
So how does it go for Rawls?
Rawls says, look.
Let's consider the following
hypothetical situation.
The original position, where
we sit behind the veil of
ignorance, not knowing who we
will be in society, and choose
the basic structures by which
our society will be governed.
The aim that we engage in this
activity with is the aim of
articulating the conditions
of a just society.
Why?
Because "justice is the first
virtue of social institutions
just as truth is the first
virtue of theoretical
systems." It is the aim of
articulating a political
philosophy to come up with one
that respects our moral norms.
Just as it is Hobbes's aim in
articulating the constraints
that govern a legitimate
political society to identify
one that respects our
prudential norms.
What then is the rationally
mandated conclusion of taking
this hypothetical situation
and this particular aim?
Well, says Rawls, just as Hobbes
thought, thinking about
the structure of the state of
nature gives us, through
rationality, the three
laws of nature.
So too does Rawls think,
thinking about the structure
of the original position with
the aim of developing a moral
society, give us the principles
of justice.
In particular, the first equal
liberty principle: that in no
circumstances are the
fundamental rights of the one
to be sacrificed for the
utility of the many.
And second, that to the extent
that there are inequalities in
the society, those are to be
associated with positions
fairly open to all and in
such a way that they are
advantageous to the
least well off.
Moreover, Rawls thinks not
just about a hypothetical
situation and the moral aim and
the rationally mandated
conclusion that we can draw from
that, but also about what
sort of mechanism, what sort
of structure that tells us
society needs to have. And his
suggestion is that it becomes
roughly one with equality and
basic rights and duties.
Freedom of speech, freedom
of expression, freedom of
thought, an equal responsibility
to make a
contribution to the upkeep of
the community as a whole.
And because of facts about
efficiency, Rawls is ready to,
at least tentatively, endorse,
as one effective mechanism
towards this, a market economy
with some tendency towards
redistribution.
So notice that it is an argument
almost parallel to
the one that Hobbes makes.
We take a hypothetical
situation.
We have an aim.
We reason our way through the
situation and determine
certain sorts of constraints.
And then we identify
what kind of social
structure that gives us.
Let's look next at what
that gives us in
the context of Nozick.
Nozick's interested, not in a
hypothetical situation, but in
a historical situation.
In particular, he's interested
in what we should do about the
fact that a particular
distribution of resources has
resulted from a series
of just transfers.
A series of transfers where
property was acquired in a
legitimate way and transferred
in a legitimate way regardless
of what that pattern produced.
Notice that although we read
only Nozick's discussion of
justice in holding and
consequently we looked at a
rather narrow question of under
what conditions it is
legitimate to own property, that
Nozick's argument with
respect to holdings can be
generalized with respect to
any sort of decision
that people make.
What makes holdings legitimate
on Nozick's picture is that
they are the result of
a legitimate process.
And as a consequence, any sort
of contract that we enter into
in a way that Nozick will call
free will end up being in the
same historical category.
So what Nozick is interested in
is the question: given that
things as a matter of historical
contingency happen
to end up the way they are in
terms of the distribution of
goods and in terms of the
distribution of contracts,
what sort of moral force
does that have?
Nozick's goal is to determine
whether this
distribution of holdings--
that is property--
and contracts--
that is commitment--
is a legitimate one.
And his suggestion is that as
long as property is justly
acquired and justly transferred,
then whatever
distribution results from that
is a just distribution.
And you'll recall that we
looked in some detail at
Nozick's idea of just
acquisition, where he
basically says, an object is
legitimately held if it was
acquired in a way where the
value that you add to the
object makes your possession
of it leave others no worse
off than they would be had you
not acquired the object.
And where just transfers are
any that are engaged in
voluntarily.
One result of that, as we know
from the Wilt Chamberlain
example, is that even if we
begin with a perfectly even
distribution of goods across
individuals, it's almost
guaranteed that we will end
up with an unequal one.
And notice that exactly the same
sort of argument that can
be raised for distribution of
property can be raised for the
distribution of obligations.
So Nozick's interested in
historical situation.
He has a moral aim, namely
determining whether the
distribution is just. And the
conclusion that he draws, as a
result of thinking about that
structure, is that any
intervention into justly
generated distribution of
holdings or contracts is
a violation of rights.
After all, the only things
that matter to whether
holdings are just, on Nozick's
picture, is whether they were
justly acquired of justly
transferred.
And the fact that, as a matter
of coordination problems of
the kind that we face in the
problem of the commons, the
fact that that will inevitably
result in distributions that
are unequal is of no concern
to the sort of historical
picture that Nozick has.
Likewise, the fact that as
a result of historical
contingency, I may end up
contracted in a way that
leaves me subordinate to you is,
according to Nozick, in no
way unjust because no
intervention into a justly
generated process
can be performed
without violating rights.
So the structurally mandated
mechanism which Nozick ends up
advocating is that of
the minimal state.
So what's the picture among our
political philosophers?
The idea is this.
Hobbes is interested in
thinking about what a
hypothetical state of nature,
considered from the
perspective of prudence,
tells us is rational.
What it tells us is rational
are certain laws of nature,
the enforcement of which is
possible only through the
introduction of an authoritarian
state.
Rawls asks us to think
hypothetically from the
position of the veil of
ignorance, what it would take
for us to have a moral society,
concludes that it
would be governed by the
principles of justice, and
identifies as a mechanism what
I've called, because there
wasn't much room
here, "Sweden."
And Nozick asks what we can
do given that an actual
distribution arose as the
result of a bunch fair
transfers and concludes that
if our goal is to respect
rights, then the only state
which is legitimate is the
minimal state.
So we spent roughly four
classes on political
philosophy.
Where to go if you want more?
The Philosophy department offers
political philosophy
courses, both survey courses
and courses on each of the
individuals that we've read.
You can take a course surveying
political philosophy
from Plato past Nozick.
You can take a course on any one
of the individual authors.
The Political Science
department, likewise, offers
historically structured courses
and courses on our
individual authors.
Nearly every course listed in
the Ethics, Politics and
Economics department is a course
that will address the
kinds of questions that I just
mentioned in this chart.
And in the context of the
Economics department and
indeed in three or four other
departments, you can think
about game theory as a way of
representing these structures
or think about policy
in the context
of an economic framework.
It's 11:19.
I will integrate the discussion
of morality and the
answers to those questions
into our
final lecture on Thursday.
But it's my hope that even if I
didn't answer all 500 of the
questions that I was asked for
today that the lecture gave
you some sense of how some of
the pieces fit together.
And we'll continue
on Thursday.